PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So good
afternoon, everybody.
I'd like to welcome you
to this session.
My name is Prakash Hariramani.
I'm a senior product
manager at Google.
With me is Michael Galpin.
He's the technical lead for a
very exciting product we're
going to be announcing today.
And I'm also honored to have
Jonathan Taylor, who is VP of
mobile at Priceline.
And he is going to be talking
about something
very exciting, too.
So we are very happy because
we are able to announce a
great product for mobile
commerce today called Google
Wallet Instant Buy.
And as you'll see, it's going to
help your users, consumers
be able to buy physical
goods and services in
a much easier way.
So before we get into the
product details, we thought we
should look at things
in perspective.
Today, when we look at a rotary
dial phone, we laugh,
especially when we have our
nice, shiny Android devices
next to us.
And we believe that the state of
mobile commerce today when
we take a step back maybe in
the future and look back to
where we are today, that's
how we'll look at
the state of mCommerce.
So what is the state
of mCommerce today?
Unfortunately, it's a
very painful state.
For many of you who have tried
to make a purchase on a mobile
device, the average person goes
through 24 plus steps
because you have to enter your
billing information.
And, god forbid, if you're
shipping information is
different from your billing
information, you have to enter
more keystrokes.
And then not to mention that
many sites require you to set
up a username and password,
log in.
And then you add all these steps
up, you could easily
have 100 keystrokes, friction,
which leads to abandonment,
which means you don't have
high conversion rates.
And one of the stats that's
staggering is the purchase
abandonment rate with
mobile commerce.
So 97% percent of users abandon
a purchase midstream.
And just to, again, take a step
back, mobile commerce is
growing at 100% year
over year.
So the question we ask ourselves
is, how much more
could this market be growing if
we were able to reduce or
eliminate this friction?
And that's where Google Wallet
Instant Buy comes in.
So how are we addressing
this pain point?
So there's a couple
of ways we're
addressing this pain point.
One is we want to have faster
checkout for physical goods
and services.
So as many of you know, by
virtue of having an Android
phone, you have Android Play on
it, the Android Play Store.
And many of you have, hopefully,
made a purchase on
Android Play.
By virtue of making that
purchase, you've set up a
Google Wallet.
And now that you already have
the Google Wallet set up, you
can use that same wallet for
making a purchase of physical
goods and services or,
for example, buying
something on Priceline.
So we reduce one friction pain
point, which is removing the
pain of entering your billing
and payment information.
The other pain point
we covered was
registration and login.
And I think many of you
may have attended
the G+ sessions already.
That's a great way to remove
this pain point.
Not only can you avoid the users
from having to set up a
different username and password,
we can also share
profile information, so
you can make it a more
personalized experience when
a user comes in to log in.
So speed is everything in
mCommerce And I think,
hopefully, you are getting
the message.
If you do step 1 and 2, you make
checkout fast and easy.
And it's all about speed when it
comes to mCommerce Security
is something that we are
very passionate about.
And there's one traditional
misconception out there that
security and convenience
are a zero-sum game.
We think that's a
false choice.
We think you can raise the
bar on both security and
convenience.
And we have done that with
Google Wallet Instant Buy.
So what are we doing
about security?
We did a couple things.
One is, every time you make
a purchase, we generate a
one-time virtual card.
This other thing we do is we
have a Google Wallet Purchase
Protection Program.
So your users, your consumers
of your application, have a
peace of mind that any
unauthorized purchase is
something they don't need
to worry about.
And most importantly, we have
risk-based authentication.
So when you have an Android
device, you're already logged
into the device.
We don't ask you to enter your
username and password.
But we do have a very
sophisticated risk engine that
will challenge your user if
it gets a risk signal.
There's two other points which
I'll just touch on, but
Michael's going to cover in
more detail, which relate
around lightweight
integration.
And the reason for that is
because our integration is
client-to-client, so
there's no back-end
elongated server process.
But you don't have to
take my word for it.
Jonathan and team and the other
launch partners, you can
talk to them directly.
And they'll talk about
their experience.
And finally, we don't charge
any additional fees.
If you use Google Wallet, you
continue to use your existing
payment processor.
Google doesn't charge
any additional
fees on top of that.
So how does the product work?
So this is actually from
our sample application.
And for those of you who will
use our SDK will also get the
source code for the sample
application.
So the typical purchase process
starts with the screen
on the left.
So I go to Checkout.
And I've chosen what I want
to buy, it's a Cannon.
I'm going to invoke the Buy
With Google Wallet button.
So typically, you would place
the Buy With Google Wallet
button at Checkout.
And when I do that, it
brings up the middle
screen that you see.
It's what we called
the Chooser.
This is the Google Wallet
Instant Buy Chooser.
So I mentioned earlier to you
all that if you've used Play,
by virtue of using that, you've
set up an account, a
Google Wallet account.
So let's say, I set up a Google
Wallet account and I
had MasterCard as my funding
instrument or what we call
your backing card, that's
what's going to show up.
That's the MasterCard you see
where it says Pay To.
You can change it to another
source, if you want.
It also has my shipping
address below.
So because it already got this
from my Play account, I don't
have to go through the
frictional pain point of
entering it again.
I also want to draw your
attention to the check box.
This is what we call
pre-authorization.
This is very important because
if your user checks this box
and gives consent, next time
when that same user comes back
to your application, they
can skip the screen.
So it makes it a 2-tap
purchase process.
Once the Chooser comes up after
the user gives consent,
we pass control back to your
site, which is the
screen on the right.
We also do what's called
a Masked Wallet.
So essentially, we pass to you
the last four digits of the
funding instrument, which is the
MasterCard ending in 5417,
and the shipping address.
And as far as you're concerned
as a developer or merchant,
it's as if the user
had typed it in.
When the user hits Confirm
Order, then we pass what's
called a Full Wallet, which
has that one time virtual
MasterCard I talked about.
And the beauty about this is
you don't have to make any
changes downstream from your
payment processing
perspective.
What I mean by that is it's as
if I had typed a MasterCard in
a mobile commerce site.
So again, it's very powerful
because it goes back to
lightweight integration.
So we thought it would be good
if we could have Jonathan now
demonstrate what I've been
talking about and give a demo
of Priceline and talk about
his experience integrating
with Instant Buy.
Jonathan, over to you.
JONATHAN TAYLOR: OK, Prakash,
thanks very much.
We'll switch over to the wolf.
Well, at Priceline, we are all
about bringing great travel
deals to our customers.
And we're especially interested
in making it fast
and easy for our customers to
book a great hotel room at a
great rate from their
mobile device.
Now, as Prakash mentions,
speed is everything.
Speed always wins.
And this is a very important
differentiator for us.
We want to make it as quick
and easy to check out on
Priceline with the Android
app as we can.
So we have teamed up with Google
to introduce a Full
Google Wallet integration
into our Android app.
And I'll give you an example
of how that works.
But first, I'll say that a wise
man once gave me some
advice, which is, Jonathan,
never do a live demo on a
wireless network.
So with that sage advice in
mind, we will do a live demo
on a wireless network.
[LAUGHTER]
JONATHAN TAYLOR: So let's
imagine that I'm a brand-new
Priceline customer.
I've just downloaded and
installed the brand-new
Priceline app, which we've just
released today from the
Play Store.
And I'll bring it up.
And I had this idea that since
we have this great spring
weather here on the West Coast,
I'll extend my vacation
a little bit and book a great
hotel room down the coast in
Monterey this weekend.
So we'll choose the
Hotel section from
the Priceline app.
Rather than San Francisco, we'll
choose Monterey, which
we've recently chosen.
And we'll check in on Saturday
the 18th and
check out on the 19th.
We'll choose one room and
do a search for that.
So let's see what's available
in Monterey this weekend.
The Priceline app is searching
for all the available rooms
and rates among all the
available hotels in Monterey.
And hopefully, we'll have
the results shortly.
Here we go.
A couple of good
choices there.
I think we'll pick the Hyatt
Regency Monterey.
We can browse through
the hotel amenities,
look at some pictures.
We can look at guest reviews and
just get a general idea of
what the hotel looks like.
And this is the normal checkout
flow for hotel.
And again, I'm a first-time
customer.
So I have not yet chosen my
Google Sign-in or my Google
Wallet method of payment.
We may need to switch
wireless networks.
Here we go.
No, we didn't quite make it.
Let me take this off
for a second and
we'll switch networks.
Almost there.
And there we go.
That looks a little
bit better.
The orientation, right?
And we have the details
on our selection.
So we'll choose Book Now.
We'll choose a great room,
coming up here, a king bed.
And we have a brand-new option
in our checkout options now,
which is a Sign-in
with Google.
So this is the Google single
sign-on option.
We choose Sign-in with Google.
And immediately, we'll be asked
to have the app-granted
permission do a couple things
in our Google profile--
access to the Wallet information
and access to the
basic profile information.
We'll say OK for that.
And what will happen is it will
choose Google Wallet as
our default method
of payment now.
And this is the regular Google
Wallet payment selector, which
Mike will talk about
in a minute.
And very importantly, we're
going to choose the box that
Prakash mentioned, which is to
use Google Wallet to pay for
future purchases.
So the number of taps the next
time through the application
is greatly diminished.
We'll say OK for that.
And right away, we have our
summary of charges, we have
our payment method as Google
Wallet is preselected.
It's copied the payment
information and billing
information from the wallet.
And we can go ahead
and book now.
We have just done our first
Priceline hotel booking using
Google Wallet.
Now, the good news is that
I'm a repeat customer.
And I come back through the
application the second time.
The number of taps required to
check out is even less because
I've signed in with Google,
which is sticky.
And I've chosen Google
Wallet as my
default method of payment.
So then I come back through
the app and decide to book
maybe another weekend
in Monterey.
I'll show you how much faster
it is the second time,
especially now that we have
a great Wi-Fi network
[CHUCKLES].
Again, we'll choose our hotel
from the available hotels.
Let's try the Casa Munras.
We'll say Book Now.
And again, we'll choose our best
rate available or choose
a room and rate combination
that we like.
We'll choose this Queen Room.
And this time through, we go
directly into Google Wallet
because we're signed in to
Google, we've chosen Google
Wallet as our method
of payment.
And immediately, we have our
payment method selected.
All we need to do
is say Book Now.
We've made our second booking
on Priceline.
This time, much faster.
So we've greatly improved
the checkout flow
for Priceline customers.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN TAYLOR: Now, the good
news is that the points of
integration from the app to the
Google Play services are
pretty straightforward.
And as Prakash mentioned, our
payment back-end systems are
changed very little because we
actually have a full-fledged
card number to pass
through to it.
And Mike will talk a little bit
more about the details of
integration.
But now, I'll turn it back
over to Prakash.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Thank
you, Jonathan.
That was great.
I should have mentioned this
earlier, but if you see
anything that excites you, feel
free to applaud at any
point in this presentation.
[LAUGHTER]
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So with
that, on the spirit of
applause, I think we
need to applaud
all our launch partners.
We are very grateful.
We have a great roster of
partners who have launched
Google Wallet Instant Buy.
And just to make a shameless
plug, we have a blog post that
was released at noon.
And you will be able to test
those applications out.
So the partners we have launched
with today are
Airbnb, Expedia, FANCY, GIGYA,
GoPago, NFC Task 10,
Priceline, of course, Rue La
La, Booking.com, Tabbedout,
Uber, and Wrapp.
What I'd really encourage
everybody to do is download
these apps and experience
the great
mCommerce experience yourself.
So for example, if you haven't
made vacation plans for
summer, I'd encourage you to try
out Priceline and make a
booking just like
Jonathan did.
We have a slew of other
travel partners, too.
If you want to try a local San
Francisco eatery, Bistro
Burger, I'd encourage you
to download GoPago.
Install it and order ahead.
I'd also encourage you to--
when you go to some of the
after-session festivities
they've organized--
call Uber for a cab ride so
you can drive home safely.
The other thing I want to
emphasize is we have many of
these partners in the Google
Wallet Sandbox area.
So I'd really encourage
everybody to show up there if
you're interested in this
product and talk to the
developers and partners
directly.
So with that, I'm going to turn
this over to Michael, who
is going to walk you through the
rest of the presentation.
MICHAEL GALPIN: Thanks,
Prakash.
No more demos, I swear.
It's really humbling to see
the list of partners out
there, a lot of great apps
using our software.
Hopefully, after you saw the
Priceline demo, you'll agree
it's a great experience
for your customers.
But you, guys, are developers.
You, guys, want to know
how this works.
So let's take a look.
So this is the Instant
Buy flow.
And you'll notice there's a fork
at the top of this flow
chart here.
And that corresponds to the
first time versus subsequent
times a user uses Instant
Buy in your application.
There's four steps involved.
The first is getting
a Masked Wallet.
As Prakash mentioned earlier,
a Masked Wallet is just a
description of the payment
instrument the user's going to
use for the transaction.
So if you use something, like
MasterCard 1234, so the last
four digits, just enough
information for the user to
identify the instrument.
But it's not the full
16 digits to it.
And it also includes
a shipping address.
So when you get a Masked Wallet,
the first time a user
uses Instant Buy with your
application, you're going to
need to show the
Instant Buy UI.
So that's the right side
of the fork here.
That's the Chooser UI that
you saw earlier.
It shows the given instruments
the user has.
So if they've bought something
on Google Play, maybe they
bought an app, you'll see
the credit card there.
If they've bought a Nexus 7,
you'll see the shipping
address that they shipped it
to will be listed there.
So they can select what they
want to use there.
And then you'll be given
the Masked Wallet data.
And with that, you want
to update your UI.
The first thing you probably
want to do is calculate the
sales tax, calculate the
shipping costs, and show that
to your user.
You probably also want to show
the Masked Wallet information
to the user so they know, OK,
it's this card that's going to
get charged, it's this
address where things
are going to be sent.
Once they're happy with it,
then they can confirm the
transaction.
And that's when you
get a Full Wallet.
That Full Wallet is just like
a Masked Wallet, but it also
includes this generated virtual
card that you can then
turn around, send to your
back-end systems for payment
processing.
So we'll go into some more
detail in these steps here.
I was really hoping Jonathan
would give us the source code
to Priceline, and we could
look at some of that.
But instead, we'll have to
settle for our sample app.
As Prakash mentioned earlier,
it's a sample application, all
the source code comes
with the SDK.
So you, guys, can take
a look at it.
On this screen, the only thing
you see going on is this Buy
With Google button.
It's important for your
users to see that.
It lets them know that, hey,
I'm going to use Google to
complete this purchase.
It's very reassuring to them.
But behind the scenes, there's
even more going on.
Behind the scenes, the
application is establishing a
connection to Instant Buy.
Now, that sounds kind
of strange.
So maybe you might want
to know what's
going on with that.
Well, to understand that, let's
look at the Instant Buy
architecture.
Instant Buy is a component
of Google Play Services.
You might have heard about
Google Play Services earlier
today in the keynote.
It's been out for
almost a year.
So you might have, actually,
already be using it.
Its a push to all Android
devices running 4EO or higher.
That includes all those
Gingerbread devices.
And they have the Play Store.
To integrate with Instant Buy,
all you have to do is compile
in the Play Services client
library into your application.
That client library is a very
thin client library.
The bulk of the code is part
of the Play Services APK,
which runs in a separate
process.
And it's because it's running
in a separate process is why
you have to create this
connection between your
application and the Play
Services process.
So creating that connection,
it's pretty straightforward.
First, you want to create an
instance of WalletClient.
This is really the main entry
point into Instant Buy.
It's the object that has all the
APIs you are going to use.
Creating one is pretty
straightforward.
You pass on an activity
through it.
You pass on the constants
[INAUDIBLE]
environment.
We have a test environment we
call Sandbox where you can use
fake credit card numbers,
so you can test all your
integration without actually
having to spend money.
You can specify an account that
ties into single sign-on,
which we mentioned earlier.
And I'll go into more
detail soon.
And a couple of callbacks.
The first is this connection
callback, which is going to
receive life cycle events for
your connection to the Play
Services APK.
So it's going to receive events,
like onConnected or
onDisconnected.
And finally, there's
a FailureListener.
If for some reason, you can't
establish the connection, that
listener gets notified
of that.
Once you've created the instance
of the WalletClient,
then you just call connect.
That's an asynchronous call,
just like all the other APIs
in Instant Buy.
So now, you're ready to
get a Masked Wallet.
There's a few things you need
to figure out before you
request a Masked Wallet.
Do you need a full
billing address?
Do you need a shipping
address?
Do you need the user's
phone number?
We really wanted to make Instant
Buy fit in with your
existing checkout flow.
So if you ask for a full billing
address, then you tell
Instant Buy you need a
full billing address.
If you only ask for a minimal
billing address-- so
basically, just a zip code of
their billing address--
then you can tell Instant
Buy that.
And that's all we'll ask
the user for as well.
So once you got all these
things figured out, then
you're ready to create a request
for a Masked Wallet.
So when you want to do that
is when your connection
callback's onConnected
method gets invoked.
That tells you that the
connections have been
established with Instant Buy.
And it's safe to call
other APIs.
So to build your
MaskedWalletRequest, we have a
very convenient builder
you can use.
And this is just where you
set all the options.
Like here, I'm saying I need
a shipping address.
When you want to set your
options, you call .build, and
you got a request ready to go.
You take that request and you
call the loadMaskedWallet
method on the wallet client.
You also pass a listener
to this.
This API dimension, like all the
others, is asynchronous.
So you pass a listener, that
gets invoked once, the data's
returned back from Google.
At this point, the first-time
users use Instant Buy in your
application, you need to show
the Instant Buy UI.
You're going to get a callback
here that will receive a
ConnectionResult.
If you happen to have used any
of the other parts of a Google
Play Services, that
ConnectionResult object should
be familiar to you already as
it's used through all the
different components.
It basically has a success
or failure method.
And in our case, success means
you've got data as a response
to the request you made.
And there's no UI to show.
So that corresponds to the
pre-authorization case for the
subsequent times a user uses
Instant Buy in your
application.
Failure, while that sounds kind
of harsh, it just means
that we couldn't return
the data to you yet.
You need to show the
Instant Buy UI.
To show the Instant Buy UI, we
rely on the startActivityFor
Result/onActivityResult
paradigm.
It's very common in Android
development.
To show the Instant Buy UI,
the listener you passed
through onMaskedWalletLoaded
method that will get invoked.
It gets passed a
ConnectionResult and a
MaskedWallet.
So you check if it was
a success or not.
If it was a success, then
you got data back
from Instant Buy.
And now, you're ready to
update your UI with the
MaskedWallet data.
If it wasn't a success, it was
a failure, then it needs
resolution.
That means you need to show
the Instant Buy UI.
Typically, you'll probably
want to put that behind a
button, probably that Buy
With Google button.
So that's what we did
in this case.
We created a button.
And when it gets clicked,
then we call the
startResolutionForResult method
on ConnectionResult.
As I mentioned,
ConnectionResult.
is actually used throughout
our Play Services.
And when there is resolution,
it's basically wrapping a
pending intent behind it.
So it's turning around and
calling startActivityForResult
using that pending attempt.
So just like anything else,
when you use that
startActivityForResult paradigm,
your activity's
onActivityResult method will be
called once the Instant Buy
UI has been dismissed.
So if everything went smoothly,
you'll get a RESULT_OK.
This is the standard result
you'd see in Android
development.
In that case, you can pull the
MaskedWallet data out of the
intent passed to you
on ActivityResult.
And then you're ready
to update your UI.
If there was a problem, like
say, there was a network
connection issue, then you can
pull the errorCode out.
We have a list of error codes
in our documentation so that
you know what each of this
error codes mean.
And you can decide how to deal
with it in your application.
So now, you've got the Masked
Wallet data, you're
ready to use it.
You're ready to update
your UI.
So you want to calculate the
sales tax and shipping, update
the totals for the transaction,
so the user sees
how much they are
going to pay.
You want to show the Masked
Wallet information, so the
description of the payment
instrument that's going to get
charged for this transaction
and the address things are
going to get shipped to.
And you should give your users
a chance to change this in
case they made a mistake.
Finally, you'll provide
a Confirmation button.
So once the user is happy with
their choices, they can
confirm the order.
When they confirm the order,
that's when you're ready to
get a Full Wallet.
So to get a Full Wallet, it's
very similar to getting a
Masked Wallet.
First, you build a
FullWalletRequest.
One thing I want to note here
is setting the Google
Transaction ID.
That's an ID that you're going
to get in the Masked Wallet
that gets returned to you.
And it lets us tie together this
FullWalletRequest to the
Masked Wallet we sent
earlier, so we know
which card to charge.
You can set some other option,
like the total price, line
items in the cart.
And then you could build
your request.
And then you pass that to
loadFullWallet , another API
on WalletClient.
And just like with
loadMaskedWallet, you'll pass
a listener to that as well.
That listener will have a single
method through the
implement onFullWalletLoaded.
And it follows a very similar
pattern that we saw,
onMaskedWalletLoaded.
You get a ConnectionResult
passed to you in
a fullWallet object.
You check if the result was a
success, in which case the
fullWallet object passed
you will not be Null.
And you can use it to send
to your back-end.
There is a chance that it
could require resolution
without a success.
This would happen if for some
reason we thought there was
something fraudulent about the
transaction, and we wanted to
challenge the user to confirm
their identity.
So in that case, you do a
startResolutionForResult, just
like you did with the Masked
Wallet request.
At this point, you're now
accepting Google Wallet.
So we'll just go over the
steps again real quick.
The first thing you want to do
is you get a Masked Wallet.
That is a description of the
payment instrument that's
going to be charged for the
user, so something like
MasterCard 1234, plus their
shipping address.
If you're ready to show the
Instant Buy UI, the first time
a user uses Instant Buy in your
application, they'll need
to show you the Instant Buy UI,
so they can pick what card
they want to use, pick
which address.
They can change these things.
And that's where they get the
option to use Google Wallet as
their default payment method
for future transactions.
Finally, once the user is happy
with things, and they've
confirmed they want to pursue
the transaction, that's when
you get a Full Wallet.
Before moving on and talking
about single sign-on and
security, I want to mention
there's a few more Instant Buy
sessions at I/O this week.
Later today, there's session
called Building Compelling
mCommerce Experiences
on Android.
That's being given by two of the
engineers on the Instant
Buy team, plus an engineer
from the FANCY.
So I really I recommend
you attend that.
They've got a lot of great
tips, even some tips that
aren't necessarily particular to
mCommerce, but for Android
applications in general.
Finally, to really get into the
details of Instant Buy, we
have a Code Lab on Friday.
In the Code Lab, you get a
chance to integrate Instant
Buy into an existing
application.
Myself and several other Instant
Buy engineers will be
TAs for the Code Lab.
So I hope to see you them.
We talked about the faster
checkout part and how that
gets implemented.
We want to go back to single
sign-on, eliminating
registration and login
for users.
On here, you see a couple of
screen shot from the FANCY.
It's an app you might
have seen from the
keynote this morning.
On the screen on the left, you
see the FANCY with a couple of
sign-in options here.
The top one is a sign-in
with Google.
There's a couple of other
buttons on there I'm not as
familiar with.
I'm sure your users will hit
that big, beautiful red button
at the top, though.
And then they'll get the
screen on the right.
They're already signed in
through their Android device,
so they don't have to enter in
a name and password to sign
with Google.
Instead, they just have to
authorize your application to
use Google.
But wait, there's more.
Once you have a sign-in with
Google+, there's some extra
benefits you get from this.
And one of those is
social sharing.
So on these screens, on the far
left, I am posting through
my G+ account about a
shaved ice machine I
bought on the FANCY.
I really love shaved ice.
And who doesn't?
That's what I wrote
in the post.
The middle screen is how the
post will appear to my friends
when they see it on G+.
So they can see my
comment about it.
They can see a description
and a picture.
But most importantly, they
see a Buy button
right there on G+.
If they press that Buy button
and they already have the
FANCY on their device, they'll
be taken directly to the
shaved ice machine listing
in the FANCY.
And there they have a Buy Now
option with Google Wallet.
And they'll go into
the Chooser.
And they'll be able to complete
the transaction very
quickly as we see.
If they don't have the FANCY
installed, they'll be taken to
the Play Store where they
get a chance to
download the FANCY.
So with social sharing, you can
really drive downloads of
the application and
engagement.
And with Instant Buy, turn all
that into convergence.
Tomorrow, there's a Google+ Sign
In for Android Developers
session that goes into a lot
more detail on how Google+
Sign In works.
I know earlier Prakash mentioned
security and how
Instant Buy makes things
more secure.
And I'm sure all the developers
in the room were
shaking their heads going,
I don't trust the product
manager talking about
security.
But he was telling the truth.
Let me explain.
So Instant Buy is easier
and more secure.
And we've seen the easier
parts already.
How is it more secure?
Well, we don't actually share
the full credit card
information with anybody.
Consumers are always hearing
about some big corporations
leaking user data, including
credit cards.
And so you can't blame them if
they have a lot of anxiety
about sharing their credit card
information with some app
they just downloaded.
So we can eliminate
that anxiety.
They don't have to share
that full information.
They've already got their
information with Google.
So they can just
leverage that.
Further, the credit cards that
we generate have a limit on
them that is closely tied to
the amount specified in the
FullWalletRequest.
So once they've been used for
a transaction, there's not
much money left on the cards.
So even if they were compromised
in some way,
there's not much damage
that can be done.
Further, they have an expiration
date that is
closely tied to when the
card was issued.
So there's really only a small
window where any problems
could happen.
Now you, guys, might be
wondering, is that going to
cause some complications
for us, these
generated virtual cards?
But the answer is no.
The card we give you is a
MasterCard just like any other
MasterCard.
So you can charge it just like
you would have if a user had
entered it by hand.
Every transaction made with
Instant Buy is also backed by
the Google risk engine because
data we get is not the only
thing users have
to worry about.
Crunching big numbers is
something that Google
is very good at.
And we use that capability.
We analyze each transaction and
challenge if we need to.
We're so confident in our
ability to detect fraud, we
offer the Google Wallet
Purchase Protection.
So any purchases made using
Instant Buy are guaranteed for
180 days after the purchase.
So again, this removed even
more anxiety for users and
helped them feel better about
making purchases.
I'm going to wrap up
now and turn things
back over to Prakash.
He can tell you how you can
get access to Instant Buy.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Thank
you, Michael.
So I just wanted to recap what
we talked about earlier today.
We talked about fast
and easy checkout.
One thing I should mention is
we commissioned Mercator
Advisory Group, which is an
independent payments and
consulting firm.
And they said, when compared to
other digital wallets and
when compared to credit cards,
Google Wallet Instant Buy was
the fastest and easiest
way to checkout on
native Android apps.
So we talked about skipping
registration and
sign-in with G+.
Michael talked about security,
kept me honest.
And then we talked about
lightweight integration and
the fact that we don't charge
any additional fees.
So I think many of you are
thinking now, I'm interested
in this product.
How do I sign up?
What's next?
Well, this product is in
limited availability.
If you are interested, what we
would encourage you to do is
complete the Interest form.
The link is here.
We'd also be in the Office Hours
section right after this
to address any questions
you have.
If you fill out the Interest
form, we'll get back to you
very promptly.
And finally, I want to emphasize
that only sign up if
you're selling physical goods
and services on Android.
So we'll turn it over to Q&A.
But one more thing.
You've been a great audience.
And when I see around, I see
many familiar faces.
Many of you have been dedicated
partners integrated
with Google Wallet
Instant Buy.
So we really feel we
should reward you.
So with that, I'm going to
turn it over to Peter
Hazlehurst, who is director
of product management.
PETER HAZLEHURST: Hi.
Thanks a lot, Prakash.
Awesome demos, guys.
Fantastic.
As some of you may have caught
the fact that we stealthily
announced a new product
at about noon today.
And that product is
the ability to
send money in Gmail.
And one of the really awesome
things about it is all you do
is, as long as you have a
wallet, you just click the
Attach Money button, attach
money like you would attach a
photo, and off the email
goes to the recipient.
If the recipient doesn't have
a wallet, we automatically
help them through the
sign-up process.
They get a wallet, they
receive their funds.
Everything's done and dusted.
It's really, really simple.
And it's just what you'd expect
from us in terms of our
integration with Gmail,
simplicity of the wallet, and
a great user story.
So we thought really hard about
how do we grow this
system and get people
using it.
And instead of the traditional
blast it out and everybody
gets it, we're doing something
a little special.
We're going to make this
a viral launch.
And the way the virality works
is if you have money, you can
send money.
And that seems rather stingy if
you guys don't have money.
So I went to my bank account and
figured out a way to send
all of you $10.
So in, plus or minus, a few
minutes from now, you should
receive an email from me saying,
"Welcome to send money
with Gmail.
And $10 is in your Google
Wallet." If you don't have
one, go get one.
And then if you're watching on
the Livestream and you want
access to send money in Gmail,
please find one of your
friends here at Google I/O
because that's the only way
you get it.
So please help us grow
the business.
And look forward to sharing
and sending
money across the net.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
Thank you, Peter.
So we'd like to open the floor
for question and answers.
And just a housekeeping note,
I know it's less than two
minutes to go, but we
don't want to cut
this discussion short.
So like I said earlier, right
after this presentation,
Michael and I will be
at the Office Hours
section in the Sandbox.
But why don't we take a few
questions in the remaining
time we have?
Go ahead, please.
Actually, yes, please go to the
microphone because this is
being live streamed.
So we want everybody on the
Livestream to be able to
listen to the question.
AUDIENCE: So I'll go because
I'm at the mic.
Jeff from Opera.
Congratulations on how far this
is coming and how much
easier it is for publishers and
e-commerce players to integrate.
Earlier in the keynote, you
talked about an HTML5 spec for
auto-complete on wallet, in
Chrome, and all that.
How do the two products
fit together?
Could you just repeat that?
MICHAEL GALPIN: So the product
shown in the keynote, Auto
Checkout, is for web pages, a
way to fill out these long
payment forms on web pages.
This is for native Android
applications.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
You said you only have
it available for
products and services.
When will it be available for,
like golden sites, like
documents or videos or images
that you want to sell online?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Yes, if I
heard the question correctly,
if you're selling these little
golden services, we have a
great product already, Android
In-app Billing.
So I'd encourage you to use
Android In-app Billing if you
are selling a product which
involve these little goods
that are consumed on
or off the device.
AUDIENCE: Quick question here.
Is any geographic limitations
as far as support or added
currencies and countries yet?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
Great question.
Actually, this product which I
mentioned before is we are
focused on the US right now.
So we do plan to expand
in the future.
But for now, the main
focus is the US.
So you need to be a US seller
and a US merchant.
AUDIENCE: I see.
The second question is around
the funding source.
You referred to using a credit
card to back a credit card
transaction.
How about other funding source,
like a debit account
or a PayPal account or something
along those lines?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Sure.
So today we support credit
cards from all the major
network brands as a
funding source.
We don't support links to
a bank account today.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yes, hi.
I have a few questions,
actually.
The first one, charge-backs.
How you handle them?
Like do I, as a developer,
get charge-backs?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: That's
a great question.
And I'm glad you asked that
because this goes back to what
we said that we have minimum
impacts [INAUDIBLE].
You, as a developer or merchant,
would handle that
charge-back exactly the way
you handle a MasterCard
charge-back today.
It's as if I entered
my MasterCard
number on your site.
And if it was disputed, you
follow the exact same process.
No changes.
AUDIENCE: And how about
if I wanted to use in
my app other forms?
So if I want to choose Paypal
and Google Wallet, am I
allowed to do that?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So we have
our UI branding guidelines.
We know, again, it's consumer
choice and merchant choice.
But, yeah, you can use other
payment methods.
But we'd encourage you to look
at Google Wallet Instant Buy
and the SDK, and then make
an informed decision.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
Thanks.
MICHAEL GALPIN: We'll
take any more
questions out at the Sandbox.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]